بخيبه امل تلقى محبو الفنانه العالميه
سيلين ديون خبر الغاء جميع عروضها للجوله
العالميه المقبله بسبب حالتها الصحيه
وصعوبه التجوال المغنيه الكنديه مشاهدينا
اعلنت في منشور عبر انستقرام انها لن
تستسلم ولا تطيق الانتظار لرؤيه جمهورها
الثانيه مضيحه انها تعمل بجد لاستعاده
قوتها لكن التجول قد يكون صعبا للغايه
وفقا لموقع بنك فيلا فان اليوم لم تحضر
العرض الاول لفيلمها الجديد
ما يشير الى تدهور حالتها الصحيه وسطه
تقارير عن معاناتها من صعوبه المشي يذكر
ايضا مشاهدينا انه تم تشخيص النجمه النجمه
سيلين ديون لاول مره بمتلازمه الشخص
المتيبس في ديسمبر 2022
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات